a lot of your duty of our streaming
network cbsn spoke to brown after recent
show black good morning good morning so
we joins a crown band for a very rare
look at its acoustic warm-up on
the Zac Brown tour bus it's an intimate
hour-long pre-show ritual that's usually
closed to the press after 22 years on
the road
this ban of eight still crams together
on Zach Browns tour bus working on their
setlist Brown says they're like a ship
full of Viking their longest break
detouring lasted just sixty days this is
a real life and it takes a lot of
dedication and it's monopolizing you
can't just go to work and come home
every day like you have to be gone a lot
but you don't get the kind of chemistry
any other way you can't fake it you have
to live this life that lifestyle though
rewarding can take a toll Zac Brown Band
draws inspiration from personal
hardships for their latest album the owl
I decided two years ago that there were
just parts of myself that I didn't want
to be anymore some mornings are being on
the road you wake up with some headaches
and so that's not anymore am i it's not
about that anymore
I think it's important to be vulnerable
and be yourself and just be real I don't
want to be around things that aren't
real anymore and I'm trying to engineer
my life the things that have soul and
things that I create some of them are
fun and then some of the things are like
me bleeding my soul in my life and my
hardship out in a song some of those
songs tell the story of Browns 12-year
marriage which came to an end last year
when did you know that it was not going
to last you know lots of things that you
don't ever foresee you know when you
live in something long enough that it's
not working anymore and that the
differences that are there are greater
and that it's healthier to not live in
conflict than it is to try to stay and
no matter how many mistakes or whatever
and she absolutely was the one and you
know that's we have five amazing
beautiful children together and that was
the reason that we were together it's
not how I planned it to be but it it
gave me more than I could have ever
dreamed of having you know Brown says
creating music about his life is his
therapy it helps me to like grieve the
things that have happened and and if I'm
doing it right then other people can to
like when I look out and see people
crying that's us doing our job and
trying to and we're always chasing that
that emotion in the songs for Zac Brown
doing so means collaborating with
artists and producers outside of country
music when I put out a record I have to
pick a category to put it in you do do
you feel that you do you have to you
release a record on iTunes you have to
pick a category 1 category you can't say
country rock reggae soul and whatever no
you get one bucket to coin yourself in I
am NOT just a country artist yeah
I'm not I love that yeah well I have to
create what moves me and what connects
with my fans and I don't really care
about their buckets but I don't like
being coined as a country artist I like
just being an artist so purists I get
them they should just listen to the
songs of mine that are more country and
leave me alone about all the other ones
because I don't really care what they
had to say about get this Zac Brown also
drop a surprise pop solo album last
month it is called the controversy I
totally honest should be allowed to go
wherever they want to go and and stop
trying to put him in lanes yeah he
really you could tell that he was fired
up about that I found him to be such a
deeply introspective musician artist
creative a little bit of that tortured
soul but also when he gets on that stage
we did that interview three hours after
he'd already performed it was late at
night 11 p.m. it's so unusual because
most artists when they're done they're
like no way exactly no I did you know
didn't know him didn't know anything
about him but I really I'm totally
smitten yeah I like what he said parts
of myself I didn't want to be any more I
liked his voice I like his look I like
him yeah like I always liked the music
now I love the beard a plus thank you
lad we appreciate it you can hear more
at night of CBS this morning including
extended interviews and original content
on our podcast